corps de métiers impactés par cette
crise sanitaire les avocats déjà
chamboulé par deux mois de mobilisation
contre la réforme des retraites
les robes noires tourne toujours au
ralenti à cause du confinement reportage
allions signer grégoire d'où ces élus
cavale face aux mesures de restriction
les avocats doivent s'adapter
consultation par téléphone des audiences
qui se font rares comme pour de nombreux
secteurs
les robes noires font face à un
bouleversement de leur organisation et
une forte baisse d'activité le cas de
françoise royannaise ne déroge pas à la
règle
moi actuellement à lyon je n'ai aucun
retour des audiences qui n'ont pas pu se
tenir c'est à dire que c'est ici dans
celle sur dix ans est absolument pas là
là j'ai vu qu'aujourd'hui donc tous les
bâtons nombreux mais des liens il faut
cliquer cliquer clics et sans arrêt pour
essayer de savoir mais tous les jours on
a des informations qui modifient celle
de la veille donc j'ignore comment
effectivement la machine va se remettre
en marche et manifestement la crise a
démontré qu'à sion judiciaire si on loue
le télétravail
elle n'est pas équipée en télétravail
françoise est pessimiste concernant
l'avenir elles redoutent notamment
d'importantes pertes financières ça
serait très difficile et ce ne sera pas
rattrapable le temps qui est passée
confiné elle va pouvoir plaider pas
rentrer de nouveaux dossiers en ce qui
me concerne je n'ai aucun nouveau client
les onze ans chez eux sont difficultés
aussi on va voir toutes les difficultés
donc la presse sera encore plus dur je
pense que le présent les aides qu'elles
devraient percevoir de l'état
permettront probablement de sauver les
meubles mais les charges à payer reste
un véritable fardeau pour le mois de
mars apparemment je suis éligible
d'après ce qu'on m'a dit mon
expert-comptable puisqu'il a une partie
de mes comptes pour percevoir l'aide de
1500 euros l'aide elle est mieux que
rien elle est la prise de conscience de
ce qu'il faut aider mais il est évident
que dans un cabinet c'est une aide qui
est très inférieur l arrêt des décharges
mais là c'est qu'un vent de ce pays il
faut payer les charges
après la bataille interrompu contre la
réforme des retraites
le confinement sonne comme un nouveau
coup dur
pour les avocats de france